[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and if i
sound a little sick first of all it's
because i am hopefully it doesn't affect
the video too much
this is the lg v40 thin q whereas i'll
call it
the v40 because that's a horrible name
again sorry not sorry so this is not a
review but it's been a couple days with
the phone
of my extended first impressions but it
hasn't even taken me that long to come
to the conclusion that this is
essentially an lg g7 thin cue
but with some minor improvements and
then a whole new camera setup that's
what this phone is all about like an lg
g7s if you want to call it that like
it's got some slight upgrades and
they're very clear but it's really about
the camera so this v40 has the same
snapdragon 845 and six gigs of ram
high-end internals the same gorilla
glass 5 and metal build and the shape
and it all has an air of quality yet is
somehow just slightly lighter than you'd
expect in the hand lg keeps doing this
but it's pretty recognizable as an lg
shape with the curved glass and the
tapered sides it has the same boombox
speaker that literally rattles the phone
when you have the volume all the way up
but it gets impressively loud especially
when on a table same headphone jack and
the 32-bit hifi quad dac to go along
with it for those who absolutely refuse
to go wireless and want to enjoy the
actual highest of audio quality it's
still here
same expandable storage via microsd same
ip68 rating for water resistance same
fingerprint scanner on the back and in
the middle where it belongs
same qi wireless charging same button
layout even with the non-remappable
google assistant button over here under
the volume buttons on the left side it's
all still here i don't hate it but i
guess i gotta still say i wish it was
remappable but it's all still here and
at the end of the day the same lg
software skin so the software experience
is exactly as you've seen before on top
of android 8.1 i'm personally not the
biggest fan of this skin as you know
i've tried it multiple times it's not my
look but there are definitely a lot of
features like a lot tucked away in the
settings as far as customization
graphics settings changing the
resolution hiding the notch all that
stuff it's not lacking in this
department at all as expected the bigger
physical changes to notice are the
display and the battery so the v40 here
now has a 6.4 inch oled display instead
of the smaller lcd on the g7 it goes
right up to the edges it doesn't have
much of a chin but has roughly the same
size side bezels and top bezel and being
an oled will make hiding the notch if
you choose to do that a little more
convincing and there's also a couple
other display features for hdr video and
app scaling and things like that and
it's the same 3120 by 1440 resolution so
crazy sharp and plenty bright so it's an
excellent display by any metrics and the
battery is bigger it's now a 3300
milliamp hour battery not best in class
on paper but i'd say it's acceptable so
now knowing all that you can tell it's a
pretty familiar phone but if you're
considering buying it you want to know
about the biggest new feature which is
these cameras they've always focused on
this
that's a horrible joke and i'm sorry but
they've always focused on a well-stocked
camera app with a lot of features so
sometimes it may seem like they're just
throwing a ton of stuff at the wall and
seeing what sticks but a lot of stuff
sticks there's a lot of interesting
useful stuff in the camera so this year
it's three cameras on the back and two
cameras on the front
why you may be asking because you
somehow haven't seen the leaks well i'll
tell you all about it because that's
what we're here to do in the back there
is a regular medium camera a telephoto
camera and a super wide angle camera and
on the front there's a regular selfie
camera and a super wide angle selfie
camera five cameras that's a lot to dive
into but this in my opinion is probably
the best use of multiple cameras that
i've seen there's no monochrome sensors
going on here no duplicate focal lengths
nothing like that it's actually three
different useful things on the back and
two different useful things on the front
it's good so let me get all the numbers
out there on the back the primary camera
is a 12 megapixel sensor with an f 1.5
aperture and a roughly 78 degree field
of view that's a normal camera the wide
angle camera is a 16 megapixel sensor f
1.9 with a 107 degree field of view and
the telephoto is another 12 megapixel
sensor f 2.4 with a 45 degree field of
view so roughly a two times optical zoom
did you did you get all that that's a
lot to think about but basically when
you see all this first thing you think
about or at least that i think about is
what would i use the other two cameras
for nine times out of ten i'm probably
going to still use the normal camera so
with the super wide lg users already
know they've been doing this for a while
whether you're taking a picture of a
building in a crowded city or a
landscape or if you're just looking for
a more creative look to a photo the
super wide accomplishes this it's great
and then the telephoto lens i guess the
main purpose of that aside from portrait
mode has always been to give a higher
quality zoom for things further away
optical zoom will always be higher
quality than digital zoom right
well technically yes given all the other
variables stay the same but here they
don't quite again it's a different
sensor at different fixed aperture and
honestly to me looks like a bit of a
different color science so i'm getting
very different white balance between the
two cameras and different image
processing even it looks like so in
practice the normal camera versus the
telephoto doesn't just look like a
straight up zoom it looks like a
different camera and also in practice
minimum focus distance of the telephoto
lens is a little further out than the
normal so these macros i wanted to take
just weren't really working i have to
resort back the digital zoom from the
main camera but that's all closer to
what you may consider nitpicking but
onto the front facing cameras
this i like this is a good idea
i don't even take selfies that much as
you could probably tell by the lack of
me talking about front-facing cameras in
most videos but this is a a good idea
for a useful difference in two different
front-facing focal lengths it's a single
normal eight megapixel selfie camera for
most of your normal front facing photos
and videos but for once in a while when
you're trying to get more in a photo
behind you or fit more people the wider
angle selfie camera will do better it's
a five megapixel and those work pretty
well you won't want to use it all the
time because it definitely distorts more
and you have to stretch things closer to
the edge of the frame to fit them in
but it accomplishes the effect you need
and i don't really have any complaints
here for my first impressions and then
just in the camera software itself they
have kept a lot of their other features
they've kept their ai scene recognition
with a lot of scenes recognized and the
automatic enhancements if you want to
turn that on and other things like that
the one thing they've added with the
triple cameras now is something called
triple shot basically if you're ever
undecided about which of the three
cameras to use just turn on triple shot
and use them all so you point and shoot
and you put your subject in the middle
of the frame with triple shot on
you press it you hold still and it takes
a shot with each of the three cameras
all in a row then it takes a minute to
save uh probably longer than i would
expect but once it does you get all
three photos from all three focal
lengths at the same time plus this
little five second video with the
absolute worst super zoom effect of all
time
seriously i don't know what the point of
this is even if it does get better with
software updates
uh is it worth it i don't know seems
silly to me but at least you do get a
full resolution copy of all three photos
overall
i don't see myself using triple shot
that much actually because i actually
want to take my time to focus and point
and shoot and decide how i want each
photo to come out and i can easily do
that here but that is it that's what's
new with the v40 that's what you need to
know on the surface
uh a lot of people considered that g7
when it came out a couple months ago one
of the more underrated phones uh that
might have been because of lg's skin
might have been under the radar for a
couple other reasons but it was pretty
good this v40 with the improvements it
makes even though it's not a direct step
from that phone
i think it does it well and i'm a fan of
the use of the different focal lengths
that lg is going to here will it sell
people who weren't already all in with
an lg phone i don't really know i think
you kind of have to want an lg phone
already and this might be the icing on
the cake but if not this might not
change your mind either way it's still
cool to see and worth considering
especially at the 900 bucks it's not
that insane thousand dollar price so a
lot of people might be interested in
checking out this phone for the first
time either way that's been it
thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace